Now, the first way I thought of solving this problem, or just simplifying the
left hand side rather, was to go through and multiply every term from the first
set of parentheses by every term in this second set of the brackets. But that
way, we end up this really, really long polynomial, and it does reduce, but
it's not very pretty. So, I'm going to show you a different way of thinking
about this multiplication. We can start off by distributing this negative sign
to each of the terms inside this inner set of parentheses. We can do this for
both of the sets of brackets. Now, this is pretty interesting. You see that we
have x minus 2 here, and x minus 2 here. Why if we see if we can just consider
those as a unit, and see what happens. At this point, we can recognize that
we're going to end up with a difference of two squares as our final polynomial.
Let's see that happen. Since we have an x minus 2 in both of these expressions,
and then opposite signs of negative 3i and positive 3i here, we end up with x
minus 2 squared plus 9. Notice I've already multiplied the i's together and
switched the sign. Multiplying out this square and adding the 9 gives us a
final polynomial of x squared minus 4x plus 13 equals 0. And this is a pretty
cool trick, definitely saved a lot of space and a lot of writing for me. And,
you know, I always love ways to be a little bit more lazy with my math.